well welcome back so away from here
whether Gary delicas should be sank from
the BBC and by the way I don't think
he's going to be at all there's been a
huge backlash over how he compared the
government's rhetoric on migrants to the
rhetoric in the 30s in Germany from
Adolf Hitler and the Nazis in his
Twitter suggested the homose secretary's
response to the small boats crisis used
quotes language that is not dissimilar
to that used by Germany in the 30s when
Jordan discusses right from commentator
Larissa Kennedy and comedian Constantine
kissing who moved to UK and Russia when
he's 11. I've still got Richard Tice
here and also uh Paula Roan Adrian is
with me as well so let me start with you
uh Larissa on this
when you read what Garner has said did
you think that was a fair analogy to
contrast this government with a regime
that was building in the 30s in Germany
which was to go on to slaughter 12
million people
to be absolutely clear what Gary lineker
said is that and I'm paraphrasing here
but the language used to justify what is
happening here with this bill with this
proposal from the government is akin to
language that was used in the 1930s in
Germany so I think it's it's really
difficult to begin then talking about
policies and actions because that is
something entirely different because I
think what Gary was trying to insinuate
is that we need to be cautious of the
slippery slope here which is well
documented which is that language and
the dehumanization that language can do
is very very powerful in leading down
that slippery slope well it is it is
right but it is but I would argue I'll
bring Constantine in here my issue with
this is you talk about slippery slope
the moment you get into 1930s Germany uh
you evoke memory of Adolf Hitler and the
Nazis and the Holocaust and 12 million
people being you know murdered
exterminated did in concentration camps
six million Jews in concentration camps
and so on
I just think that is a slippery slope
and the moment to me anyone invokes that
in relation to a current government like
this conservative government to me
you're losing the argument you're using
an extremity of a debate which just
Bears no relation to reality
well right and I'm not particularly
easily offended so I'm not offended by
his comments but the problem we've got
here is not so much that he said
something silly or insensitive for me
the problem is it's completely
inaccurate tens of thousands of people
we're not trying to get into Germany on
small boats and that is I'm afraid the
real problem with this whole argument is
the people who want to demonize Britain
is This Racist hellhole can never seem
to explain why tens of thousands of
people like me want to come to this
country and settle here and some of them
do so illegally even by breaking the law
and putting themselves in danger which
is something actually I think we should
all be concerned about and should be
seeking to end yeah I mean my problem
Arissa with this Gary Gary doesn't have
a solution to one of the biggest
problems with the small boats at the
moment which is a third of the people
coming in on these small boats are young
perfectly healthy non-vulnerable
Albanian men who are being recruited
they suspect mainly for gangs and
already in the UK they're being brought
over by Criminal gangs they're spending
thousands of pounds to do it so they're
not short of a few quid but these aren't
the most vulnerable oppressed people
from war-torn countries they're coming
from a perfectly safe country and they
you they're abusing our system but I
don't see anything in Gary's statement
about that reality of the people coming
over on these small boats in large
numbers
to be really clear we are often talking
about people being trafficked here and
in fact by not being trafficking
people of their rights
there are people being trafficked to the
UK there are being people people
repeat the question and so you know
better than genocide watch you know
better let me repeat my question because
your rights organizations
let me repeat my question a third of the
000 or so people who came over last year
to the UK on small boats were Albanian
young men perfectly healthy not
vulnerable not oppressed people for more
torn countries that's a that's a fact a
statistical fact and when I saw that I
found that alarming that said to me the
system was being gained now there are
other people who are coming from
war-torn countries in fact Britain has
been leading the way in putting up
people from Ukraine from Afghanistan and
other genuine war-torn places that is a
different issue but what would you do
about all these young Albanian men
coming in who are not from more torn
countries and just want to come in
without doing it legally
what would I do well I don't think my
first action would be to strip all of
those all three-thirds of those groups
of their rights illegally by
contravening international law I don't
know how the the question is being
reversed rather than the government's
actions actually being interrogated
because at the moment we are
contravening international law in 1951
we signed up to the conventional
refugees saying that we would not uh you
know put extra pressure or you know
impose sanctions on those who came via
illegal entry we signed up to that as a
country so it's not for me to now sit
here and debate okay
this is a problem
I mean there certainly is going to be a
massive legal route about this but what
is your response to that
well this is exactly the problem and
this is nothing personal to Larissa but
the people who who pretend to care about
these people never seem to have a
solution to the problem and the reason
is they haven't thought about the issue
at all now look at the point you made
about people from Albania being uh
smuggled let's say that they are being
smuggled why are they being smuggled
into this country because we allow them
to be uh to be coming in here in these
small boats and we don't do anything to
prevent it from happening and we don't
do anything to disincentivize these
smuggling gangs from doing it right and
all we have to do by the way is declare
Albania a safe country so that no one
who comes here from Albania illegally is
entitled to Asylum it's not very
difficult if you actually care about the
issue and my biggest concern is someone
who like you is proud of Britain for
helping people who are coming from
genuine uh need is that if we continue
to make the British public feel like
they're being taken for a ride and of
course they're right to feel that way
once we spend seven million pounds a day
accommodating these people if we
continue down that path then eventually
people are going to get fed up and say
we don't want anyone coming in we don't
care about the circumstances and then
the very people that these woke lovies
like Gary lineker pretend to care about
are going to be the one that suffer in
the end I mean to be fair to gardenica
everyone shouted them well if you care
so much take one of them into your house
and he did he took in a young boy
Refugee and he did take care of him and
he's very proud of him and so he did
actually practice what he preached um
thank you both but that's not the
solution peers no no I totally agree and
I I've in my son column tonight I've
I've said where is the answer Gary and
secure starmer and others criticizing
the government where is your solution
because I don't see one and the problem
with allowing so many obvious economic
migrants to come in illegally is that
you are then taking attention and money
and resource away from the people who
really need it and that is what we
should be focused on as a country but
Larissa Constantine thank you both very
much indeed